there's a
recent really exciting breakthrough of
alpha 2 uh
of alpha fold 2 solving protein folding
or achieving state-of-the-art
performance on protein folding
and then i thought
proteins have a lot to do with viruses
it seems like
being able to use machine learning to
design
proteins that achieve certain kinds of
functions
will naturally allow you to use maybe
down the line not yet
but allow you to use machine learning to
design
basically viruses maybe like measles
like for good
which is like to attack cancer cells
but also for bad is that
is that uh is that a is that a crazy
thought or is this a natural place where
this technology may go i suppose as all
technologies can which is for good
and for bad do you think about the role
of machine learning in this
oh yeah absolutely i mean alpha fold
uh is amazing you know it's an amazing
algorithm
a series of algorithms and it does
demonstrate
to me it demonstrates just just how
powerful
you know everything in the world has
rules we just don't know the rules you
know we often don't know
them but you know our brain has rules
how it works everything is plus and
minus there's nothing in the world
that's really not
at its most basic level positive
negative
you know it's all obviously it's all
just charge
and and that means everything you can
figure it out
with enough computational power and
enough in this case i mean
machine learning and ai is just one way
to learn
rules uh it's an empirical way to learn
rules and it's but it's a
profoundly powerful way
[Music]
and certainly now now that we are
getting to a point where we can
take a protein and know how it folds
uh given its sequence we can
reverse engineer then we can say okay
we want a protein to fold this way what
does the sequence need to be
we haven't done that yet so much but
it's just the next
iteration of all of this so let's say
somebody wants to develop a virus
it's going to start with somebody
wanting to develop a virus to to defeat
cancer
something good you know and so it would
start with a lot of money
from the federal government uh you know
for all the positives that will come out
of it
but uh we have to be really careful uh
because
uh that will come about there's no doubt
in my mind that we will develop
we're already doing it we engineer
molecules all the time for specific uses
oftentimes we take them from nature and
then tweak them
but now we can supercharge it we can
accelerate that the pace of
discovery to not have it just be
discovery we have it be
true ground-up engineering let's say
you're trying to
make a new molecule to stabilize
somebody with
some retinal disease right so we come up
with some molecule that
can improve the stability of somebody
with retinal degeneration
uh you know just a small tweak to that
to say make a virus that causes the
human race to become blind you know
i mean it sounds really conspiracy
theoryish but
uh but it's not you know it's we're
learning so much about biology and
there's always nefarious reasons i mean
heck look at
how ai and you know just google searches
those can be um you know they are every
single day
being leveraged by nefarious actors to
take advantage of people
to steal money to do whatever it might
be
eventually probably to create wars or
already to create wars and i mean i
don't think there's any question at this
point
behind disinformation campaigns and so
it's being leveraged this thing that
could
be wholly good you know it's always
going to be leverage for bad and so how
do you balance that as a
species i'm not quite sure well the hope
is as you mentioned previously that
there's some
that we're able to also develop defense
mechanisms and there's something about
the human species that seems to keep
coming up with
like ways to just just like
on the deadline just at the last moment
figuring out
how to avoid destruction i think
i'm like eternally optimistic about the
human race not destroying ourselves
but you could do a lot of things that
would be very painful
yes well we're doing it already you know
just i mean we are seeing
how our regulation today right we did
this thing it started
as a good thing regulation of medical
products
but now it is uh you know
unwillingly and unintentionally harming
us
our regulatory landscape which was
developed wholly for good
in our country is getting in the way of
us deploying a tool
that could stop uh our economies from
having to be
sort of sputteringly closed that could
stop
deaths from happening at the rate that
they are and
it's um you know i think we will come to
a solution of course
now we're going to get the vaccine and
it's going to make people lose
track of like why we even bother testing
which is a bad idea but
but we're already seeing that we have
this amazing capacity to
to both do damage when we don't intend
to do damage
and and then also to pull up when we
need to pull up and you know
stop complete catastrophe and so uh
it's we are an interesting species in
that way that's for sure
you